ring in the new year with something
sweet
ethel um chocolates is hosting a fun
virtual tasting
mercedes spoke with them on what we can
expect
when it comes to celebrating the
holidays there is no sweeter place
than to do it at ethel and chocolates
and henderson and i have lisa vanderson
from ethelam
joining me to talk about all the great
things that you can do
to celebrate it's so festive where you
are lisa i love it
it is thank you mercedes it's great to
see you
what is the santa experience i'm hearing
about for the kids
this year you can come out and i think
there's one tomorrow and then every
almost every day next week
you get an hour ansa you get to taste
two
chocolates with him cup of hot chocolate
our delicious hot chocolate
and a chocolate dip cookie and then you
can just sit socially distance from
santa
talk and get your picture taken so it's
a nice more one-on-one
experience with him but outside in the
pavilion completely safe
masks on we have picnic tables you just
need to bring your coat
now how do people get in on that that
sounds like something i would love to
take my kids to
yeah that's a great question so you just
have to go to flm.com
and look at the holiday experiences tab
and you can book that and you guys are
doing something really special
for new year's what's this all about we
are so if you're staying home we have
the perfect answer
uh this year we started doing virtual
chocolate tastings
because we couldn't have people in the
house right so we will send you
a box of our new truffles in this cute
ethylene bag
we'll send you these mats so you can
take notes we'll send you pens and then
of course the best part
we'll send you the box of truffles and
then mark mackey our chief chocolatier
will take you through the hour-long
journey on how to really taste these
chocolates with all of your senses
so i don't know if you're like me you
just throw it in your mouth that's the
right way to taste it you really should
rub it smell it there's a whole list of
things that he'll walk you through
and it's really fun and since it's new
year's eve we're also going to send out
champagne pairing recommendations
so you can have those too thank you so
much for your time lisa
thanks good to see you happy holidays
ethel m chocolate's new year's eve
virtual chocolate tasting happening on
december 31st at 5 p.m
includes a 12-piece truffle tasting go
to ethelchocolates.com
rocky